tu sais ce qu'il te reste à faire
sabrina réclame le trône sont de
précieuses green day est source d'un
petit ami
se lève
[Applaudissements]
tu peux pas continuer comme ça je peux
pas penser en faire tout le temps est
fier je pense pas en faire tout le temps
je pense tout le temps
lorsque l' équilibre interne avec huile
en va de même au paradis
tout comme sur la terre pour préserver
un royaume il te faut préserver tous les
autres styles
ou bien un nouveau propriétaire à moteur
source sûre de vouloir faire ça tu fais
bien les b
et c'est reparti
tu veux la couronne il va falloir s'en
montrer digne ça c'est ma fille
reine des enfers et un travail à plein
temps notre commune est en crise tout
faire pour ton petit ami occupa de moi
tu as kobe l'assemblée sauf que l'une
d'elle ma famille
mais comme tout ce qui comprend
[Applaudissements]
vers sept morts comme ça qu'on en
finisse g
[Musique]
je suis ulcéré après le purgatoire on a
droit aux enfers et ensuite le paradis
[Musique]